hey guys it's alex the other day i was
browsing the internet because i was
pretty bored and i came across a vintage
recipe that was so bizarre and so random
that i wondered if i could take that
same recipe and turn it into something
super delicious so that's what i'm gonna
do
this recipe is from 1973.
it was published in mccall's great
american recipe card collection and it's
for ham and bananas hollandaise yeah you
take a bunch of bananas you wrap them in
mustard and ham and then you cover them
in hollandaise sauce i'm gagging a
little bit just cutting it apart that's
not fun
now you guys know i love bananas but i
have to say this takes it too far
so i'm still gonna try to use the key
elements of this dish i might you know
deconstruct it a little bit add a couple
things but for the most part i want to
keep the spirit of the dish alive even
though i don't know if it really should
be alive
the ham kind of reminded me of a
croquema dam so a crocodile is like a
croak monsieur with an egg on top it's
almost like an elevated grilled cheese
sandwich but it's super creamy and gooey
and cheesy and delicious so i'm gonna
add some banana to it this might be
really good or it could be totally
bananas
now the original recipe calls for a
hollandaise sauce but to stick with the
croque madame theme a little more i'm
going to go with the bechamel it's going
to go in the sandwich on top of the
sandwich it'll be great because great
because it's a super mild flavor i mean
it's just butter flour and then your
milk so i think it could go with a lot
of things like bananas
you just want to whisk it pretty
constantly so that it doesn't burn or
end up clumpy
looking good
nice and thick so now i'm just gonna
season it with a little bit of salt
and a tablespoon of dijon mustard so in
the original recipe the mustard was
spread on the ham that was wrapped
around the banana which is a little
weird so to incorporate the mustard in a
way that made sense i thought it would
be really nice to add the mustard
directly to the bechamel i'm going to
give it a try
that's actually really nice it's not too
mustardy but it has a good tang to it i
think this just might work so now for
our banana i am gonna slice up one
banana
now in the original recipe the bananas
were left whole but i think by slicing
them it might make it a little bit more
palatable
so now i'm going to put my sliced
bananas in a bowl and top them with a
little bit of lemon juice this will help
prevent the bananas from browning it's
also another element that they did in
the original recipe this is so weird
good next this is where it gets a little
crazy
it's not already so first i'm going to
start by spreading some of our mustard
beige chameleon on both slices of white
bread
[Music]
so i'm going to top the bread with a
little bit of swiss cheese now gruyere
is more classic to a croc madam
but i feel like swiss is a little bit
more common and i'm hoping that the
tanginess of the swiss cheese helps in
cutting down some of that sweetness of
the banana so now i'm gonna top the
cheese with our banana
[Music]
so in the original recipe the ham was
wrapped around the whole bananas here
we're sticking it inside the sandwich
kind of like ham is supposed to be used
and then finish it off with even more
swiss cheese
and now just place the other slice of
bread right on top
that is a big sandwich
all right so now we're gonna cook this
baby so she gets really nice and melty
and gooey and delicious
[Music]
all right i'm gonna put my sandwich on a
foil lined baking sheet and we're going
to top it with even more bechamel
[Music]
that is looking real good
and even more cheese
all right now i'm going to pop this baby
in the broiler to melt down the cheese
[Music]
so now we're gonna put a delicious fried
egg right on top because that's what
makes it a croque madame
[Music]
honestly this looks pretty delicious the
cheese is melty and crispy got that
fried egg on top i know the bananas are
a bit of a wild card probably a pretty
big wild card all right let's cut this
baby open shouldn't cut the baby don't
cut the baby
[Music]
oh yeah
that runny yolk there's nothing like a
runny yolk
all right it's time to try it i'm
actually kind of excited
here we go
i'm into it
i'm actually really into it honestly
it's super delicious you get the
saltiness from the cheese
that egg that gooeyness from the
bechamel and then just a hint of
sweetness from the bananas they're
not like aggressive it just adds like a
nice little sweet tang it's a little
weird
i could eat this whole thing
i'm into it
the original dish was like banana
blasphemy but this
this is a banana blessing you're welcome
okay here is my mom
so mom i'm gonna let you try what i made
[Music]
i think i praise you for your creativity
[Music]